Aaron is on the line in Columbus Ohio hi
Aaron how are you I'm doing great
thanks for taking my call today sure
what's up well I got a call today
my kids are hopping in the van saying
that I had to call a collection agency
for a $590 debt or I would be facing a
lawsuit and it's not a debt that I
recognize I was wondering if this is
some sort of scam hoping that I'll just
pay it because I'm scared yes or or what
well I think if you have no recognition
of the debt who are they saying it's
from well through her thick accent all I
could understand was the words first
recovery service that's it sounds like
that's the right third party that's the
collections company yeah and so you're
just going to say yeah you know you can
sue me if you'd like be prepared for me
to counter sue you for ten million
dollars okay because I don't owe you
anything and if you have if you want to
send me proof of the debt and details
about the debt if I can ascertain that
it's mine I'll be happy to pay it but I
don't think this is my dad I think you
have a wrong number okay well they also
actually also called my mom so they have
her cell phone number and they called
and the same so my message was that
doesn't matter all they've done is
researched out you and somewhere they
found a connectivity between you and
your mother but they probably have the
wrong Erin should I worry about identity
theft you might yeah but you might be
where it might be just a scam - okay
because they did reiterate my last four
of my social and it was correct really
uh yes well that's interesting because
they she just me to verify and well he
said it's the last four and you know she
said it I said she gave it to you you
didn't give it to her she said it to me
yet okay well that's fine just say
you're going to need to send me here's
what I would do if you want to call them
back under the federal is what I would
say under the Federal Fair Debt
Collection Practices Act
I am formally telling you to send me
proof of this debt and the details about
it when I ascertained that it is
legitimate I will pay it instantly until
then I won't
we're going to sue you today good sue me
and I will counter sue you for ten
million dollars because under the
Federal Fair Debt Collection Practices
Act I have just given you a formal
demand for proof of debt okay just get
all up in their stuff let me tell you
the company that called you is scum of
scum if you go on FTC's website federal
trade commission gov gov you're going to
see how many times they've been nailed
and fined okay they're horrible
should I be worried that the number was
instead of being like an 800 number it
started with eight four if I have your
if they have your Social something's up
okay that's the only part of this that
legitimizes it okay
prior to you telling me that I was
pretty sure it wasn't even you okay but
apparently they it is something
somewhere to do with you either its
identity theft or something some bizarre
thing out of your past you've forgotten
or something so could it be that they've
hacked into something that we did do in
the past there's no telling but just
tell them to send your proof and you
know just mail it to my home address
c'mere my home address that's fine no
RPO or whatever you've got you send it
to me and we'll be happy to look at the
information and and if you know starts
getting unreasonable just say listen
this conversations over because you're
an idiot okay would it show up on my
credit report if this is something
legitimate if I pull all my bureaus they
might okay but you know and look for
their name and look for the similar
dollar amount okay but uh yeah you can
delete for identity theft protection
yeah you can't really buy insurance
after the house burns okay but but I
would this this probably gives you a
good wake-up call to go to Xandar
insurance and get the identity theft
protection and they might help you walk
through this if you were to buy it now
but I mean don't get don't get four
months into this and then try to get
them to help you that's not going to
work it just happened this afternoon
yeah so I mean crawl you know what you
might do is call them and see if they'll
take it if you buy from them I see see
if their caseworker will take it and
handle it for you okay because the
company that's calling you is that's an
offshore dollar is what that is is why
you have the accent and they're just
they're just horrid they're absolute
bottom feeders
so the stupid debt could be 15 years old
okay that's the kind of crap they're
doing so have you ever been through a
bankruptcy yes actually we were 10 years
ago okay this could be pre bankruptcy or
something from that okay this company
has also been charged in several others
that are bottom feeders like this see
when you go through bankruptcy the debt
that's listed on your bankruptcy you no
longer oh that's the purpose of
bankruptcy right yeah and what they'll
do is take old debts that are not
collectible because they were bankrupted
and so it's completely illegal it's
against federal law to collect them
you're in violation of federal court
action which is federal bankruptcy court
to try to collect them but there was a
big article in The Wall Street Journal a
few months ago of them trying to collect
these uncollectible debts anyway and
they keep selling them and then they
drop them in these boiler rooms or these
offshore dialers that they pay no
nothing to and just hassle the crap out
of people and it's a small enough amount
and people sometimes just get scared
because they don't know their rights and
pay something because they get
threatened like you were oh so that now
I'm back onto something this thing's
probably in your bankruptcy file okay
that would tell me follow the company
you out it was back in 2005 was when we
went there and it was a chapter 13 we
repaid and it was that would fit hurt
that would fit the profile of this
company to try to collect on an
uncollectible debt okay but you do need
to get the bottom up because it's going
to raise its head up and they're going
to cause you a hassle at the most
inopportune time and you can't control
the timing of their crap unless you get
aggressive about it okay so yeah I
really would go to Xandar insurance by
the insurance protection see if they'll
take that case and run it for you if you
buy from them I don't know if they will
or not but ask them and if they will if
not either way I bother in the identity
theft it's not that much and then I
would just dig into this thing and get
all up in this offshore ladies face be
prepared for a battle over five hundred
ninety bucks this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button
to get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show I
want to write a song I want to own my
own business I want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish